foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
the United States
[Music]
house
of Representatives is still derelict in
their Duty because of Republicans
and only because of Republicans you know
that I believe that this
is democracy at work
that's what this is we have an image
here of Kevin McCarthy Owen six
he's a bigger [ __ ] loser than Donald
Trump if you can believe it
what a [ __ ] loser
look
everyone
um wants to know exactly what's going to
happen and when are we going to get a
speaker
it's the big question who is it gonna be
who's it gonna be
when are they going to become speaker or
when are the Republicans going to get
their [ __ ] together
is this really how a democracy works
this is how our democracy works
you're watching
how our democracy is supposed to work
before your very eyes
and I know I keep beating this horse to
death but we have to
we clearly have to understand that at
this point in history
that what is happening
in the United States House of
Representatives
is exactly why we feel tension in this
country
and I'll give you the reason it's
because the minority ideology holds the
majority
in some of our government
right now in the federal government
the minority ideology the Republican
party because really frankly they don't
have any ideology besides
no in fascism
they're against all equality they're
against all Equity they do not want your
they do not want you to have individual
freedom
and the American people want that
and that's why they're having trouble
picking a speaker
they really don't have a party
to be frank
and we should politicize the [ __ ] out of
this but this is how our democracy works
is it dangerous you damn right it is
you damn right it's dangerous to our
national security
that we have the minority ideology party
the America First Nazis
trying to come up with the speaker in
the House of Representatives
it's dangerous and you say well Tony
Hakeem Jeffries has received the the
simple majority of the votes each time
and he will continue to do that
because the Democrats have a
pro-democracy coalition
and they have coalesced around the idea
that our democracy must stand
we played a clip yesterday of AOC and
Matt Getz it was a bad lip reading clip
it's funny
but the conversation that actually
happened was AOC basically told him
we're not moving [ __ ]
there is going to be no movement from
Democrats
it only shows the desperation of people
like Matt Getz
they know they're losing and they're
losing badly
the only way that they actually possess
the majority in the House of
Representatives to continue this [ __ ]
chaos
is because they gerrymandered districts
they don't want people voting on them
based on their policies and their ideas
they have none
they want them voting on them based on
affiliation and imaginary borders
that's what they want you know they're
always complaining about the southern
border and protect the southern border
and blah blah blah yakity smackity
but there's no one that loves more
imaginary borders than the Republican
Party
how do you think they get power anywhere
they do not represent America that is
why they can't find a speaker
the best part about our democracy is
there's term limits and you say oh well
Tony there's no term limits to a member
of Congress the hell they're written
in 2024 we get to term them out
you the people get to vote them out
cause that's the trouble that we have
is because they've gerrymandered these
[ __ ] districts
what has happened it's not just
gerrymandering that is not the only
problem don't don't don't take this that
gerrymandering is the only [ __ ]
problem that is not the only problem
party affiliation voting based on
affiliation is a is a long-lasting
problem in this country and it's a human
condition unfortunately
that will take us a long time to make
sure people understand that you're
affiliated with the wrong group of
[ __ ]
your beliefs and your principles are not
with them
the America First Nazi party that is
but they gerrymandered these districts
where this country voted
for them to be in the majority
but they do not hold the majority of
ideas in this country they don't they
won't
and some would say well Hakeem Jeffrey
should be the speaker because he got the
simple majority no
that is not how our democracy works
that is not how our constitutional
Democratic Republic works
we have a two-party system in this
country
a lot of people don't like it tough [ __ ]
that's what it is
and if you're cheering for it to be torn
down you're with them
you're with them
this is the most beautiful display
of how inept
and how far down the conspiracy theory
rabbit hole
that we have the Republican Party quote
unquote the one of the major two parties
in this country
it's on full display
and there's nothing better
than for the American people to see now
rather they'll that rather they'll look
or not is the question
that is the real question whether
they'll look or not
will they will they not it's hard to say
I can't guess
I can only do the best that I can do
to shed sunlight because I believe it is
the best disinfectant
so McCarthy goes Owen six
now today we're going to have uh in
McCarthy's walking on the floor right
now as we speak let me see if I
let me see if I can bring this up
um
I never dreamed really honestly that we
were gonna have uh three full days of
watching the house floor it's [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
but here here is the house adjourn uh a
rea convening
for the 118th Congress now
these people are not elected they're
elected Congress people but they're not
sworn in
and that's why it's so important for you
to understand how our Republic works
because you know there's these [ __ ]
idiots out there in your thread they're
like we're not a democracy we're
Republic no we are Republic yeah sure
but it is a form of constitutional
democracy you bonehead
and this is the actual display
of we the people and our government
when we give these [ __ ] idiots a
chance to gerrymander districts by
electing them into state legislators you
have to understand this the reason why
Republicans gerrymandered districts
isn't because they just oh wow just
falls out of the sky it's because we the
people elect them to go do that [ __ ]
we the people we are the government not
just the federal government but the
state government the County government
you're you're your [ __ ] road district
your school board you are the government
it's a democratic constitutional
republic they represent you they vote
for you
and because of that
that's why Hakeem Jeffries is not the
Speaker of the House
we the people as a collective whether
you like it or not I don't [ __ ] like
what's going on I would much rather the
Democrats
one in New York one a few more seats
didn't get gerrymandered down in Alabama
and and a couple other red States
and won the house of King Jeffries would
be the goddamn speaker of the house but
that is not what happened
we can't look backwards and go oh well
that butt hurt that's what liberals do a
lot and that's why you lose
you want to know what we do we
politicize the ever-loving [ __ ] out of
these chuckleheads these morons this
[ __ ] show this clown car
that is the America First Nazi party
they don't care about their constituents
they don't give a [ __ ]
otherwise they'd have kicked McCarthy to
the curb after three boats
they'd have found someone they have no
one folks there is no one
there is no one we had David bender on
the other day he was thinking McHenry
nope it's not going to happen I don't
believe Upton's gonna be I believe we
are going to be two or three weeks into
this
without a speaker
I don't know how they come to a deal
they don't even have a party
and this is why it is so important for
us to understand our Democratic Republic
is we aren't the [ __ ] government and
when when we the people rather when we
elect [ __ ] to gerrymander our
goddamn congressional districts
because we vote on affiliation because
folks that's what's happening they're
just voting for ours ah they're [ __ ]
Republican I vote for them I voted for
poke in my whole life my daddy voted
Republican his daddy my daddy her
they're not voting with common sense
and they're not voting based on how our
government works
if they did we would have a speaker we
would have had a speaker on Tuesday
but here we are at Thursday and these
[ __ ] idiots are still gonna nominate
Kevin McCarthy for more rounds of losing
and we should be cheering it to be frank
us is in the pro-democracy Coalition why
do you think the Democrats
are standing on the floor and voting for
Hakeem Jeffries and not backing down
you gotta hand it to the Democrats
Democrats could just walk off they
really could Democrats could walk off
the floor not vote and Kevin McCarthy
would receive a majority of the votes
and he would be speaker
but the Democrats are making the
Republicans pick their speaker
they're making them pick a speaker you
have to govern they can't they won't
they don't want to the reason why is
they don't want democracy so why would
they be any good at it
should you be pissed absolutely and this
is what happens when you put people who
don't know how to govern in government
we talked about it before and everyone's
like oh why are big cities liberal well
big cities are liberal because they have
to govern dummy
there's a hell of a lot more to govern
in a big city than there isn't a rural
area trust me I know there's not a lot
of [ __ ] in a rural area to govern
and when you have to govern when you
have to know policy and be a policy
maker and be a serious person you are
liberal
that is what happens
and you are seeing the strength of
liberalism
it is absolutely crushing authoritarian
authoritarianism on the house floor
yesterday Tuesday today it will
absolutely beat down
authoritarian authoritarianism on the
floor
because the 20 members and there's more
than 20 members uh Lauren bobert was on
Hannity last night I'm going to show
this clip eventually at some point today
we're handy and Lauren bobert are going
back and forth and it's like a [ __ ]
sandwich feeding a [ __ ] sandwich another
[ __ ] sandwich it's [ __ ] dumb dumb as
dog [ __ ] these people are
but Lauren bobert said something I think
is very significant in that clip
and I think it's the truth
what do you know she might tell the
truth every once in a while
that there is more than 20.
there is more than 20 that do not want
Kevin McCarthy to be speaker
but it's a go along get along type thing
right
but this is what happens this is what
happens when you believe in
authoritarianism because they're
terrified they're terrified
they're terrified that they're not going
to be able to pick their authoritarian
leader of the House
so much so that they're willing to strip
away pound-for-pound every single piece
of speakership away from Kevin McCarthy
he's got to trade everything away
and ultimately maybe that's how they
find the speakers they find someone
that's willing to trade their entire
speakership give the entire power to the
caucus
in its entirety and really the rules
committee is where it lies if you're not
familiar with the House of
Representatives
if you're not aware the rules and that's
what they're arguing and [ __ ] dip
[ __ ] from Ohio yesterday gotten he
I forget his name he uh he has Boehner's
old seat right you know you remember
John Boehner
the guy who cries when he's talking
about mopping up his dad's bar
that guy
the reason why Kevin McCarthy is even
even in line for speakership in the
first place because John Boehner liked
to smoke cigars and drink brandy with
this [ __ ] fool
they're Brandy buddies that's why Kevin
McCarthy is up for speaker
the idiot from Ohio said yesterday
that there's 20 at least 20 members in
the house caucus the house Republican
caucus that do not trust Kevin McCarthy
and he's nominating him like he's trying
to speak
as if he wants him to be speaker and
he's saying he can't be speaker because
there's all kinds of people that do not
trust him they don't trust him they
never will trust him we've seen a clip
yesterday of Bob good maybe we'll get to
it today where Bob good says I will
always vote no [ __ ] Kevin McCarthy I'm
never gonna vote for him and good for
you Bob good you Nazi
good for you
but the representative from Ohio not
only
they let the cat out of the bag set the
quiet part out loud that no one trusts
Kevin McCarthy why would you I mean how
how [ __ ] easy would it be or hard
would it be the way you look at it to
trust a guy who on January 6 says oh
yeah goddamn right it was the [ __ ]
Cheeto dust mobster that that stoked the
crowd and they came in the capital to
try to buy buy only overthrow our
government overthrow the vote and then
not two days later he's down Mar-A-Lago
kissing Trump's ass
cheated us knee pads on in the last few
days calling him begging him to post
something on [ __ ] fraud social for
him
I wonder how much he had to pay for that
post
oh you know he paid for it oh that
wasn't free
that [ __ ] wasn't free and you know
that Trump is calling and calling
causing chaos in the caucus of 20 if you
want to call it that
but this idiot from Ohio while he's
saying the quiet part out loud that the
caucus does not trust Kevin McCarthy
this is what happens when you have a
bunch of fascists is they don't trust
each other paranoia really sets in with
authoritarians it really I don't know if
you've seen pictures of Putin here
lately but he won't let people come
within 500 yards of him when
authoritarians take power they get more
and more paranoid as it goes along
and they are [ __ ] paranoid
of Kevin McCarthy that he is not going
to be the authoritarian that he says he
is and wants to be
but the [ __ ] from Ohio as he's on the
floor nominating Kevin McCarthy he lists
off all the things that Kevin McCarthy
gave to the Congress people because
that's what this is about
that's what this is about
power why do you think that
gerrymandered the districts you think
they did it because they thought it was
fair you think they did it because they
thought they could win those elections
anyways with ideas [ __ ] no they did it
for their own power
their own power not the power of the
people
not the power of the country not not for
the constituency not for the American
people not for the people who live here
and work here pay taxes here
they have to live here under under
economic conditions no they didn't do it
for them they did it for themselves and
they continue to do this [ __ ] for
themselves
by begging begging anyone anyone that
will let them be on a committee or
subcommittee or chairman give me the
gavel Lauren bobert says yesterday
people keep playing that [ __ ] clip of
Lauren bobert talking about Trump and
they forget the end
that [ __ ] bonehead
has been in Congress for two [ __ ]
years
two [ __ ] years she she's barely in
Congress now with just 500 [ __ ] boats
after she's done doing the Trump thing
where he should tell Kevin McCarthy to
[ __ ] off or whatever the hell a clip is
she says I yield
that is not how you yield back the floor
you have to yield back she doesn't even
know how to [ __ ] yield her time on
the floor of the house
What What In [ __ ] God's name would
you want someone who doesn't even know
how to yield their time back to the The
Quirk
not only being a member of Commerce but
nominating someone as the Speaker of the
House
and going on national TV over and over
and over again acting as if
she's some kind of King maker with 500
votes sit down Lauren bobert and shut
the [ __ ] up
foreign
you are barely a congressperson frankly
barely got enough brain cells to be
considered
considered for a member of Congress
Jesus Christ you can't even you don't
even know how to yield back your time
the clerk and and I know it seems
nitpicky folks this is why they can't
pick a [ __ ] speaker
they don't even know how to yield back
their [ __ ] time
they don't even know the simple rules on
the [ __ ] floor when they're in front
of a microphone
and we expect them to pick a speaker get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
my guess is I I would not be surprised I
would not be surprised if there is no
business on the house floor besides
voting for Kevin McCarthy for the next
two or three weeks
100 percent
foreign
I believe they'll keep voting
for Kevin McCarthy Dan Bishop a Republic
from North Carolina is on the floor now
I don't know who the hell he's going to
nominate it's probably going to be this
Byron Donalds again
they found their black token
that they can nominate
it looks like that's what's going to be
the case
what a shameful shameful shameful turn
of events
you expect anything else from these [ __ ]
boxes
really
is there anything else that you that you
see coming out of these
just these vile pieces of gross garbage
I mean
in the grand scheme of things would
Kevin McCarthy
being speaker
today tomorrow next week
absolutely fundamentally change our
country no and the reason why is because
he's ineffective it's clear
nothing's been more clear than than
Kevin McCarthy's ineffectiveness In This
Moment
I mean if you compare it
to the last speaker that we had over the
last two years with the same [ __ ]
margin of votes
by the way almost the exact same slim
margin in the house
and you look
at what Nancy Pelosi
and David Bender says she's the most
effective uh speaker of the house that
we've had in our history I know it's
definitely in modern times and lover or
hater
Nancy Pelosi knows the house
and she knows the house business
and she knows how to get the business
done
that's effectiveness
when you have a great speaker you have a
damn good set of rules for your caucus
and for the chamber
to make sure when you bring things to
the floor that you can get them past the
floor
now
on a daily basis C-SPAN and the house
floor is boring as [ __ ]
I I would not venture
into the into the realm of absolutely
showing you the house floor every single
day on this show no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way
but one of the other problems that we
have in this country besides
gerrymandering that has delivered us
the minority ideology as the majority in
the House of Representatives where they
cannot pick a speaker because of that
fact it was delivered to us by
affiliation that's right affiliation
votes
this is the problem that we have in this
country people vote
because their daddy or their mama
or their their Pastor said
they vote against their own [ __ ]
interest in affiliation now here's
here's and it's also third party
endorsement not third party like a third
party as in like an independent or green
party
it's like I'm a professional athlete
endorsing a tennis shoe and telling you
hey these are really good tennis shoes
I love to wear these tennis shoes
they're the best tennis shoes go buy
these tennis shoes
and you go by the [ __ ] tennis shoes
that's third party endorsement
right
it's affiliation
ah maybe it's your favorite team maybe
it's your favorite sports store
got it so you have a favorite shoe
that person buys those shoes so I'll buy
those shoes that person at work says I
should vote for them so I'll vote for
them everyone around me says I have to
vote for Nazis so I'm going to go vote
for Nazis
affiliation and third party endorsement
is the problem we have now it's it's
it's spread by a lot of delusion I don't
know if you know but this is you this is
a q Anon World we're just living in it
folks
this conspiracy theory there's lies this
nonsense that these people are dredging
up
and using the internet and Facebook and
like
to do it has made it even harder to get
away from affiliation at this point
but when the tennis shoes suck
when the tennis shoes are [ __ ]
garbage they fall apart after two times
wearing them
they don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna buy
another shitty pair of tennis shoes
because that person says they're great
tennis shoes and they wear those tennis
shoes and they should go buy those
tennis shoes
affiliation and gerrymandering are the
two problems that have delivered us
this [ __ ] majority in the house of
the minority ideology
that cannot pick a speaker
and this is the beauty of a Democratic
Republic
because these are our votes regardless
of how we got here regardless of the
imaginary gerrymandering borders it
doesn't matter that's this is how we did
it we did this
the people we are the government
and until we get that fact buried deep
inside our conscience we will keep doing
this [ __ ]
now
I don't care if it takes them two weeks
three weeks six months I don't care if
it takes them two years and they don't
have a speaker of the house
what I'm gonna do and what you should be
doing is politicizing every single step
of the way and mocking the [ __ ] out of
them
embarrassing them and embarrassing
anyone
that voted for these [ __ ]
chuckleheads and would ever vote for
Republican ever again you have to make
fun of their [ __ ] tennis shoes
and the person selling those [ __ ]
tennis shoes
and the company making the [ __ ]
tennis shoes that's what you have to do
you have to mock them
you have to give them sunlight it will
disinfect this over time it's going to
take a while but they do have term
limits folks these aren't even members
of Congress you got to remember that
these people aren't even [ __ ] sworn
in as members of Congress yet
we have not formed a government in the
United States House of Representatives
because we the people took our eye off
the ball of democracy
and we are having to relearn what our
Republic and what our democracy truly is
and when we do that when we do that
we will fix the problem
that we are having this week everyone
stick around we're going to be with
we're going to be right back with live
coverage
from the house floor right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ] em we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
we're back we're back we're back
democracy of work today
oh yeah three days of observing the
house floor and Kevin McCarthy
absolutely losing we have this same
[ __ ] nominees here Kevin McCarthy
King Jeffries and Byron Donalds and
we're gonna have the same result now
here it is you can see here's the house
floor uh let's let's turn on the volume
a bit see if we can hear them boating
and I'll turn on closed captioning here
that way you can see it in case I turn
the volume off or empty
Gabe Sanchez is going to be joining us
in just a minute
um also Today's Show May end just a bit
early
um I may have to pick up coverage for
the minus touch Network it is possible
so I want to let the audience know
here's what will happen okay if you are
on this broadcast we're gonna go for
another hour and a half here watching
the floor giving you the commentary that
we normally give you here at the Tony
Michaels podcast but if I have to pick
up the coverage for the Midas Dutch
Network here's what will happen remember
stay on this link do not leave this link
we will redirect it automatically
so if you're on this link right now at
the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube uh
if you're not go to YouTube because we
will redirect to their coverage and I um
possibly will be taking over their
coverage I'm not 100 on this yet but it
is possible
um and then I'm gonna take their
coverage at the top of the second hour
so I may I may cut out just a bit early
if you're listening again if you're
you're here every day and you know how
this works
um at the top of the second hour if I
cut out early it's because I'm I'm going
to be going to the coverage of the mind
of stats Network and um I I I'll have to
take a quick break and then come back on
theirs so
again if you're on if you're on this
link now if you're watching it on my
channel on YouTube which you should be
you should subscribe if you're here go
down and click the Bell notification
so you're notified of every single
episode every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific here on YouTube uh this link
will redirect at the top of the second
hour now for continuing coverage as long
as there's continuing coverage because
we don't know what's going to happen
here we have no I mean we do know
McCarthy is going to continue to lose
notice my TV my TV is not working behind
me I don't know what the hell is going
on I have no idea if you're wondering
what's going on behind me with the TV I
can't get it to turn on so
yeah well these are the technical
problems that you have yeah that's why I
was a little late I was trying to figure
it out anyways and we're back to the
house floor here for the third day of
votes I'm gonna mute this [ __ ] um for
now Jesus this is going to be the same
[ __ ] over and over and over again
um and I don't know how long they're
going to do this frankly and Kevin
McCarthy
I don't know how many beatings he can
take now I would imagine once he gets to
20
.
um
20 no Vote or 20 votes
and 20 ballots as it would be referred
to
I believe that is going to be a time for
him to walk away from this now I believe
that yesterday maybe when they adjourned
um you know last night that Steve
scalise would make his move now maybe
scalise tried to make his move and it
didn't work
I actually think that um there are
members of the House of Representatives
that do not want a speaker they don't
want a speaker no one to be speaker
they don't want it
they want a king is what they want
it's what they want but Lauren bobert
made the rounds yesterday let's see if
we I can blow up those clips and while
we're waiting on them Gabe Sanchez to
join us let's see here bobert
see if I can pull up some of these um
these clips here
um Lauren bobert she was on Sean Hannity
Show last night and I'll be able to show
you the uh
the nonsense
that they're [ __ ] these [ __ ]
sandwiches are trying to toss around
it's really stupid stuff uh oh here's a
new one uh Michael uh
oh she goes she goes on Michael Noles
show this morning apparently and says uh
they're the nails in the coffin Kevin
McCarthy is not going to be speaker
which means that Lauren bobert knows or
maybe she's just [ __ ] lying I mean
it's hard to know at this point with
this bonehead she doesn't even know how
to yield back her time on the house
floor
the clerk
had to say do you yield back question
mark and she said yeah yeah you're back
she kept saying yield you gotta yield
back your time back to the whatever you
know I know a nitpicky that a member of
Congress after two years should know how
to yield back their time when they're
speaking on the house floor
you know Jesus
[ __ ] it's like trying to
give the expectation that someone's been
driving their vehicle for two years and
knows the difference between the
the gas pedal and the break for crying
out loud this is simple stuff
it's not like she hasn't been doing this
or has she hmm maybe that's why she only
won by 500 boats now let's see let me
see if I can um
pull this up as we as we watch the house
floor now let's switch here to the
bobert clip
on Michael Knowles show talking about
how oh looky here
lucky here okay so here is the um
the clip from this morning uh I haven't
watched this this is the first time I've
watched it you're seeing it as I see it
uh let's let's let's listen to these
boneheads I'm sure it's I'm sure it's
riveting
is is the trust now just irreparably
broken that is to say
if Kevin McCarthy came out and issued a
statement said okay I'll give you a
single member motion to vacate okay I'll
give you this that or the other thing
one would that change your vote and two
would that change enough votes to to put
him into the speakership I know you've
suggested maybe not but but just to be
totally clear are you saying that
from the people you're talking to
McCarthy's speaker candidacy is is
actually dead it is dead I'm gonna you
jump all over here it is dead not only
is McCarthy's speakership dead if he
continues this he will not be a gangers
person I would bet
McCarthy continues to lose today and
tomorrow into the weekend
that he will resign before George Santos
resigns his seat in congress not just
walk away and withdrawal this you can't
you can't do this and not resign this is
horrible
Kevin McCarthy maybe that's why he's
continuing this this beating and this
losing streak
is because he knows if he if if he stops
if he withdraws and walks away he's done
you have to resign you can't you can't
how are you going to action but they're
Republicans so don't put it past him to
staying in Congress as he presents the
American people how ineffective as a
congressperson he truly is
but you know let's see what the clown
has to say
it's dead yes the nails are in the
coffin and uh there are plenty of
members who are cheering our efforts on
who are afraid of Retribution
um we were threatened in conference it
was it was a nightmare in there oh my
God it's such a [ __ ] snowflake
threatening you [ __ ] were
threatening him you dumb [ __ ] listen
this I I'm sorry I can't I can't help
but this [ __ ] absolutely absolutely
was threatening you give me this or I
won't vote what do you think a threat is
[ __ ] out of here with this nonsense I
want to point something out I want to
point something out
um on January 3rd Tuesday the day we
came back from our break
the title of the show my show number
301. I just want to point this out the
title of the show and I type this title
in this is my title
January 3rd episode 301 was Kevin
McCarthy doesn't in capital does it have
the votes for speaker
I knew then that he didn't have the
votes for speaker and I and I presume
that he wouldn't I didn't know that they
couldn't coalesce around someone
but when you have boneheads like this
that don't know how our government works
they don't know how Republic Works they
don't know how the Constitution Works
they don't know how
democracy works
they have no [ __ ] clue these are the
results that you get when you elect
these boneheads
when we elect people to gerrymander
districts and states to make sure that
this [ __ ] idiot
has a chance to win by 500 votes in
Colorado
these are the results
garbage in garbage out
it is us that is the government and
that's again the problem but let's
listen to this problem that we have on
the screen we were threatened um by
steering
um committee members who who actually
assign committees to members of Congress
that um if we vote against Kevin at all
we will not receive committee
assignments and Kevin McCarthy that
that's how it works dummy
I I just I don't understand how these
politicians who have won elections don't
get how elections work this is an
election you [ __ ] bonehead
it's an election
how don't you know how this works
that the rules are what the speaker
controls and that's how the speaker does
their job
in getting legislation to the Florida
the House of Representatives
the other job is to make sure that you
have the votes when it comes to the
floor
they really just don't [ __ ] know and
that's why I know it seems nitpicky that
I'm like yield or yield back but this is
why
this is why that's so important because
this [ __ ] bonehead doesn't even know
that she doesn't even know this is a
national election that we the people are
voting through them they have no [ __ ]
clue they're more worried about what
gavel they're gonna hold
then what it means for their
constituents that elected them to go
vote for a [ __ ] speaker that's your
first job your first job is to bring in
the new Congress and vote for a speaker
you dumbass
affirmed that he stood up and said your
District elects you your conference
elects what committee you are assigned
to
um and so trust is broken
um as it stands for me I am a no on
Kevin and there are too many others who
are there uh who don't allow him to get
to 218 he doesn't have the numbers
Michael
wow that's that's really really big and
I have to tell you I know that people
are pulling their hair out over this
especially in the establishment GOP I
think this is the same stupid ass that
helps Ted Cruz with his show is that
right
I don't know uh Gabe Sanchez has enjoys
all right I check with him but I I think
this is the same [ __ ]
and this the same [ __ ]
that helps take cruise with this show
I I think so
I'm pretty sure it is
someone on Twitch says Tony's got a
dopamine Rush
from this stuff [ __ ] yeah
listen this is really important [ __ ] I
don't I don't think anyone understands
just how much that the United States
House of Representatives is the people's
house like it's called that for a
[ __ ] reason
they are our true Representatives
senators in the founding of our country
in the framing our country they were
they were appointed by Governors they
weren't [ __ ] elected
you elected a person that appointed them
from your state
and they're and their their terms are
every six years and we only get two per
state no matter what the [ __ ]
population is
so there's way way wildly
misrepresentation in the Senate of the
actual people
but the house for Representatives is
where the funds are appropriated
originally
before the executive branch after
Franken D Roosevelt
took a lot of power in the executive
branch the House of Representatives held
all the power you didn't want to be no
[ __ ] Senator you wanted to be a
congressperson
and the reason why we we the people have
so much control over Congress the House
of Representatives is because we get to
turn these [ __ ] out every two years if
they suck
but we don't understand it we do not
understand that as a collective whole in
this country
the majority of this country does not
understand how our government works and
really you're looking at two of them on
the screen right here when Michael
Knowles and Lauren bobert this stupid
ass she's saying [ __ ] about
subcommittees and committees because the
caucus controls it yeah you dumbass
this is how this is how the United
States House of Representatives is
supposed to work now you get the you get
to determine the rules
when you're the majority
and the Speaker of the House gets to
control the rules committee and frankly
why the [ __ ] would you want someone like
Lauren bobert who has no clue how to
yield the floor back and her time back
to the clerk
why in the [ __ ] would you want that
person in charge of rules that control
that actually determine how businesses
run on our our us the people's house
floor
you wouldn't that's why people in
Colorado that voted for this idiot are
[ __ ] boneheads
because they voted for her because of
affiliation and God's guns Gentry PPP we
love Nazis
stupid ass [ __ ]
no one in their right mind that actually
understood how this [ __ ] Works would
ever
ever cast one [ __ ] ballot for this
clown
let alone more than that okay let's uh
check back in with the house Lord it
looks like Kevin McCarthy
is it 77
oh we got others we got others there's
news big news uh big news someone voted
for an other
uh on on the ballot which is a change
this is a change slight change there was
one present one other vote so step is
moving it's moving in the direction of
Kevin McCarthy never to becoming speaker
no and the Republican party not being
able to do their jobs all right so let's
go back to the house floor here and see
what we got going on let's listen
hell
a car thing
Heinz
Jeffries
Henson
McCarthy
horseford
Jeffries
halchen
McCarthy
Houlihan
Jeffries Hoyer
Jeffries ah we're here's Gabe Sanchez
how are you this morning Gabe good
um he finally did it who did it Gates
what what did he do did you miss that I
well I I was talking about the Lauren
bobert clip on Michael knows this
morning Matt Gates just voted for Trump
how did you miss that oh my god let's go
back get give me the clip give me a clip
let's play it it's gonna be out there
you're gonna have a tweet and I'm sure
in the chat they're like what the [ __ ]
are you doing look I'm trying to I'm
trying to make sure that people
understand and I really thought that
this was going to be um he voted for
Trump huh well see that's that's
actually different than what he promised
that's different than what he promised
he still has not uh he said he would
nominate Trump not just vote he said he
would nominate right and that what the
clip in that his exact words
yeah but
voting is not nominated it will it will
be in the next following rounds
oh and actually you think he's gonna I
think they're gonna switch again
so wait wait this is good okay so what
you're what you're proposing is exactly
what Trump doesn't want
yeah he's gonna lose oh he's gonna lose
he's gonna lose this round because he's
his name is now in the batch and when
they make it official
he's gonna lose again
well I mean I you know that maybe
maybe the title of the show today in
True Form is great for that because I
the title to show today is Kevin
McCarthy is a bigger loser than that but
I put Trump on there originally but
right well I know I know the thumbnail
today did have Trump and bobert on it
because bobert I I don't even know why
that she went on this media tour uh
yesterday
I mean this is crazy that people think
she's the person to go to there's a
there's a part of me that's like because
she was on the she was on the 11th hour
last night and there's a party right
with Stephanie I saw part of that clip
where and part of me is like uh I don't
know if I would give
like coverage to a Nazi sympathizing
insurrectionist election night
see you next Tuesday
I did call her I did call her [ __ ]
earlier yeah it worked I mean I tried to
be selective but she is and word fits
really well I think here's the thing
yeah
I get what they were trying to do but at
the same time it's like does the MSNBC
crowd need to see her they already know
who she is
so giving her air time
to then spew a bunch of I mean like look
yeah she said the quiet part allowed to
live oh we're willing to wait till the
cherry blossoms come in I don't even
think she knows what cherry blossoms are
or Where cherry blossoms actually come
from
but she's on the 11th hour last night
giving they're giving her time
and I honestly think
that it was a a misstep by the 11th hour
I don't think they needed to do that I
think they could have done way way much
more by just playing clips
from the from the actual uh right she's
been in my room microphone it doesn't
mean well she doesn't need to be she can
go on all the other press stores Hannity
can make fun of her they can play those
clips over and over again
here's the thing don't you because we
talked about this before though is that
they're really not in it for the members
of Congress and I know I'm again I'm
being nitpicky when she didn't know how
to yield back the floor yesterday but
she she's been a member of Congress for
two years and she had to stand there and
say yield three times before the clerk's
like you mean yield back she's like yeah
yeah that's what I mean yeah that's it
I'm yeah yeah but but but Sanchez listen
she is not in this to be a member of
Congress she is in this for social media
influence for her to be famous it is not
about her constituents it is not about
policy making yeah it's not about any of
that [ __ ] none of it it's only about
getting in front of a microphone and
yelling and screaming like I do and why
you do not have to be a member of
Congress to do that trust me you don't
there's all things there's all kinds of
things you don't have to be to yell and
scream and remember microphone but here
is speaking of um idiots in front of a
microphone Matt gatz is another one of
these chuckleheads that is not really a
member of Congress there are social
media influencer that just happens to
hold one of our seats in our government
here's here's him voting for Trump
thank you
Father John Trump
John Donald John Trump yeah you think
through the J in there that RJ
John Donald he gets the jacket he fixes
it up yeah Donald John Trump I would
have laughed if he [ __ ] I was like
Donald James I mean uh John Trump you
know like well okay Donald James Trump
got it we don't know who that guy is but
we'll get him you know what is
significant about that clip at the very
end after he says it there's no huge
rousing Applause no not at all seems
significant if you ask me I that's why
that's why I laugh that's why I laughed
at you when when you said he's gonna be
the he's gonna be one of the the
nominees here the official nominees he
who there is there is so much confusion
this party is so Dazed and Confused
they're pointing fingers at each other
it has not stopped since the midterms to
say
it's not my fault it's their fault uh
they they did it they they're the ones
who who are at fault they're the ones
who ruin this for us they're the ones
that did this XYZ and I mean here's the
thing Kevin McCarthy [ __ ] lost again
he's oh and seven
uh I have to tweet out the new image of
it yeah yeah it's official he he I mean
unless I'm just wondering doctor starts
not voting but right there's a part of
me that's like how much
should I uh I'm just
I have ideas for what I want to do but I
don't want to do them all early
yeah right you know uh you know I was
thinking yesterday because I text you
that you know you might even have to
show Kevin McCarthy absolutely
decapitated here and knowing how Twitter
is I probably won't get banned for it so
well you know as well and you know
[ __ ] it what's the difference right it's
speaking in Twitter I was um
um uh on Twitter this morning and did
you know Elon Musk thought that he's a
king maker of all people who thinks that
they can sway
um opinion in this country elon's like
oh yeah Kevin McCarthy should be speaker
which leads me to believe that he is he
is not ever going to be speaker
but also Elon Musk didn't even vote in
the midterms
what yeah he did not vote in the
midterms so the fact that this guy is
injecting himself to be like oh he
should be the speaker and I'm
independent is the dumbest [ __ ] thing
I've ever heard if you want to give
commentary and and complain about the
politics of of the state of our country
and economics and and social programs
and how we you know budget these
different departments and things like
that fine vote you can have a say you
can elect who you're local to official
or to to uh to state to to government
official but if you're gonna [ __ ] and
moan about stuff and then say oh well
I'm actually independent
and then not vote
but then throw your two cents in to say
oh I think McCarthy should be speaker
you don't have any say you you cannot
give your two cents because you didn't
actually participate well I mean it is
his freedom of speech to be stupid but
here's the here's the problem that we
have and I said this in the in the a
block the problem that we really have
here is that you have boneheads like
Lauren bobert like Matt gatz like Bob
good like Scott Perry and Thomas Massey
and the list goes on and on with gozard
and I mean these are these are just
typical [ __ ] authoritarian America
First Nazis right that's what it is but
the problem is is not that Elon Musk
didn't vote it's that he has no clue
what he did when he didn't vote he
doesn't know he doesn't underfully
understand that the reason why Kevin
McCarthy can't receive the speakership
is because maybe he didn't vote he
doesn't understand that look the reason
why Republicans are having trouble in
the house right now and Kevin McCarthy
cannot receive
in our democracy in our constitutional
Democratic Republic
the votes to become speaker is because
of not enough people in this country
participated in this last election and
we had record numbers Sanchez we had
record numbers and but the problem isn't
that they didn't vote or that they use
their freedom of speech to say really
stupid [ __ ] like Elon Musk did the
problem is is they won't correct they
don't they don't know hey you know what
maybe next time I should vote that way I
don't have that way we don't have this
problem
because if I vote then then the House of
Representatives would be more
representative of the country and it is
likely that they will have a speaker
like I don't know Hakeem Jeffries who
could who could more we would already
have as we'd had a speaker at [ __ ] 12
30 12 45
on Tuesday because we started voting on
right different actual like actual
legislation have been voting on by this
point in time
um but you know the Republican party
wants to kick around the idea that
they're the actual ones that are in
control they are the ones who are going
to be making the rules they have the
majority but
I mean even on the 11th hour last night
it was it was very obvious especially
for the questions that were asked but
also the responses that were given by
bobert is they don't they don't have a
plan like well I mean I guess their only
plan is to wait until I think she
literally said or was it Marjorie Taylor
green that said that I think it's
Margaret Taylor green that was on Steve
bannon's show that said we have no plan
there is no plan I mean she might have
said that I I don't know I I know there
was a clip of her the first day I think
after she came out she was like he's bad
in the head of [ __ ] and moan about the
other side but I mean here's the thing
you've got one side that's calling uh
the other side domestic terrorists and
the other side is uh complaining about
the fact that they're called domestic
terrorists then you've got people on the
house floor last yesterday
who are saying oh the Democrats are
eating popcorn I got their blankets and
having alcohol which of course someone's
going to respond negatively when you
when you say oh they've got alcohol on
their side why wouldn't you be drinking
at this point though this is yeah I mean
but even but then of course but then of
course when they complain about it they
say oh they got so upset oh there must
be some truth to that I know they all
went out for drinks after after they
were adjourned hey I went out for drinks
I went out for drinks last night see you
were you were trying you were trying to
make sure I was uh up the speed on the
on on what was happening with the
hearings last night or the the the uh
reconvening last night what was it eight
Central
um they they reconvened and they
adjourned
um they voted because that's the only
two things they can do right now they
can vote to adjourn and vote for a
speaker that's that's their business
right now
um and but you were keeping me abreast
of this last night because I was
drinking I was drinking yes and one of
the reasons
why if you see crackles in my voice it
may be the tequila shots I'm just saying
um here is um
speaking of shots of tequila you need
about 50 of them to listen to this
bonehead but let's do it anyways this is
this is uh a [ __ ] sandwich eating a [ __ ]
sandwich okay this is the Sean Hannity
Show which is typical you know
run-of-the-mill [ __ ] sandwich type stuff
for Sean Hannity but here's lone bobert
and they do not agree on the lot both
lies of that both of these people are
telling let's listen I mean you tweet uh
Town Hall quoted you today saying the
president you you said complimentary
things about President Trump needs to
tell Kevin McCarthy that sir you do not
have the votes it's time to withdraw
let me turn the tables congresswoman
Kevin McCarthy is 202-3 votes your site
has 20. so if I'm going to use your
words and your methodology and your math
uh isn't it time for you to pack it in
and okay here again this is fundamental
to why these people always are
disappointed in their [ __ ] losers is
because they TR Sean Hannity a [ __ ]
pundit a commentator on our government
and the politics of it doesn't
understand how our Democratic Republic
is [ __ ] founded
with the House of Representatives
it you have you have to form a
government a speaker
it doesn't those 20 members could do
whatever the [ __ ] they want
Matt Gantz can go on voting for Donald
Trump for the next two years if he wants
to and never be a congressman only be
Congressman elect until we have the next
election
but Sean Hannity fundamentally does not
understand how the people's house Works
listen the problem that we have is
Lauren bobert is a representative of a
district it's stupid it's dumb why do
those people do that [ __ ] [ __ ] we go
over it every day here and I want to
re-ash that but by 500 votes this [ __ ]
has a seat in Congress and has the power
of those people in that District's vote
for the speaker
this is how it works and when you as a
person who is a member of the government
because you're a citizen and you're
registered to vote go and vote for dumb
asses like this
these you get dumb ass results that is
what happens and of course of course
Sean Hannity clearly doesn't understand
that but let's see if Lauren bobert
understands it I doubt it your side of
the packet in considering he has over
200 and you have 20.
Sean I understand the frustration I
promise you but I'm not frustrated you
didn't answer my question
you're not answering my question of what
we're doing and they're cheering us on
so there are more for us than are
against us and they are waiting for
Kevin to keep
um I gotta say this this is more
delicious than those tequila shots that
I had last night this is I mean
absolutely you don't like tequila shots
no look I like I like tequila yeah I
like you just like it in other stuff
yeah it's just like I don't know I mean
like I learned later on in life
that shots have uh they're like uh
it's like an acquired taste yeah well
you know everyone gives me [ __ ] because
I like Jagermeister they're like oh my
God I'm like no that's that I would
prefer a Jagermeister shot over tequila
hmm I don't drink beer much anymore I
drink shots you gotta you know you gotta
watch your girlish figure you can't be
drinking too much beer
um anyways let's get back to um if
you're um Donald's is at 17 right now is
he really okay let's go okay well now
the question is so that's one for others
17 for Donald's will we get another
present from spats at the end I don't
know yeah let's see if she spats herself
let's see if a boered here spats herself
are certainly frustrated by I'm
frustrated by you not answering a direct
question you said to president Trump you
you said earlier today that President
Trump needs to tell Kevin McCarthy you
don't have the votes can I finish
candidate to elect it can I finish the
house you don't have the votes and it's
time to withdraw he has 203 your side
has 20. why is it time for him to
withdraw and not you when he has so many
more votes
well Sean he needs to maybe maybe maybe
Hakeem Jeffries should get those votes
maybe they maybe they should maybe maybe
these Republicans should just withdraw
in Sean Hannity's Theory here Gabe
Sanchez these he you could use the same
logic because the king Jeffries is way
more popular on the house floor at this
point than Kevin McCarthy has ever
dreamed of I mean King Jeffries really
has won the simple majority every single
time I believe I mean if we were if we
were in a conference final he'd have
done one in the conference final right
yeah I mean he would have done one
but that's not how it works this it is
our government and you have to have in
the majority to elect a speaker the
person who leads the House of
Representatives because it is the voice
of the people
you have to have a majority and you
[ __ ] are in the majority Lauren bobert
being one of them and you [ __ ]
had plenty of time to sort this out and
that is the problem here is they are not
going to sort this out I actually I
actually believe that um
because we were kind of texting back and
forth yesterday uh and I was actually
texting David Bender
um after uh they they adjourned and
we're gonna come back I thought Steve
scalise was going to make his move
um did you think that Steve scalise is
going to try and it's like you didn't
think he was going to try this line I
thought if he was I thought if Steve
scalise was going to make a move that's
where it was
uh no I just think there's too much uh
there's too much confusion and dissent
within that party that they don't know
what to do and we saw that yesterday
where Kevin mccarth they were like all
right we're gonna come back in to figure
out if we're gonna vote tonight and and
I think last night it was just gonna be
for one vote it was just me for the
seventh because I didn't see anything
that would indicate that it was supposed
to be additional votes beyond that but I
could be wrong well because he wanted he
wanted to dunk that seventh vote but
he's not gonna do this so I want which
means he would have lost two votes last
night which would have been funny
um
but I don't I don't think that uh
uh I I feel like it's too early on
um it's we've been watching this for
three goddamn days
this is three goddamn days
what I will tell people is this will
definitely not be resolved
before 10.
um vote rounds of votes uh historically
when this happens it it never gets
resolved like if it takes more than
three it never gets resolved do you
think he goes to 20 do you think
McCarthy goes to 20. I think he's
definitely going 12 plus rounds
um
I don't see them budging really uh
uh in the sense of
[Music]
um
people are saying to check the chat yes
yes I've I already we already checked
the chat here it is we already checked
the chat uh the DMS
um but in a sense what's the problem
what's the problem they're telling us to
check the DMS but I already checked it I
sent you the link for what they're
talking about
go ahead anyway
um
okay sorry uh 12 votes 12 votes is he
gonna go past 12.
I think it'll I think it'll be longer
than 12 rounds for sure uh we're at
seven right now he's already lost this
one he's gonna go in an eighth one it
won't be resolved by the eighth one
um I think it will take a car thing
I could see possibly 20.
I think
that's where Kevin McCarthy May draw the
line um this clip that they sent this is
uh of Ali Alexander I don't know if you
can you explain why I pulled this up to
the audience you this one yeah so this
is the people keep telling us to check
yes this is what we're this is what
we're about to pull up and so I I'm
assuming that people are delayed in the
chat and that's why they're uh they keep
saying it but uh the clip that we're
gonna show that the mods were uh getting
us to talk about is a clip
um this is from right wing watch and
Ellie Alexander is threatening to
release evidence that representative
Margaret Taylor green committed a crime
uh oh who knows was it a bomb I don't
know a bite Palmer maybe a pipe Palmer
that will get her expelled from Congress
I will not suffer this Harlot I will not
be Tau I will not be taught vows and
loyalty commitment from a [ __ ] I mean
they're really they're really doubling
down on this
um
do you like when Nazis fight I love it
when Nazis I mean I I'm look this whole
the week started the week started with
grabbing a bag of popcorn and grabbing a
drink and I mean we really I mean it's
it's oh boy
2022 tied the bow on it with Andrew Tate
we haven't even been able to get back to
that store yet
um and then 2023 is starting to give you
an update I can get I can give you
another one yeah yeah remember that
Bugatti he was like I got this Bugatti
with this third ejection 33 cars right
right well Romanian uh police sees them
all so oh that so he doesn't have them
anymore
how many how many cars did they seize
was it 33 no uh I believe it was 11
because yeah he was 11 because he
doesn't own
um from what I was reading hasn't
actually own all 33 no of course he
doesn't it's what I said he's renting
these [ __ ] things so he can take
pictures
okay let's watch
speaking of uh farts let's watch this
clip here I'm sure it's um
I'm sure the thing that Alec Ali
Alexander says is the absolute truth and
nothing but the truth so help him Trump
I will
I will I will not be taught vows and
loyalty
I I'm I'm I at first glance
this starts off like a Kanye rant that
we heard several weeks ago when he was
on all his tour is is I love Hitler too
are you remember speaking of that see we
haven't heard from Kanye either hey he
went dark you want an update on Kanye oh
yeah sure I'll give you a local update
he got evicted he got uh so he's got a
spot out here in La yeah where he's like
headquarters were which is where when
you saw footage of him with
um Nick Fuentes and also uh milianopolis
right they were at his his uh the Yeezy
headquarters right well the uh the owner
of the building the landlord evicted him
because he did not pay the rent and he
had a certain amount of time a few days
or whatever to pay the rent and they're
like if you don't pay this then you're
getting evicted so Kanye
no longer has that place of uh of
residence so that's the last I've heard
that was beef that was like right around
Christmas okay it looks like I have
everything now
um in the house floor I I hate to
they're going to be pissed off that I'm
switching back but I got to switch you
notice my TV isn't working what the [ __ ]
yeah I saw that what can I tell you
right now it's McCarthy's got 199
Jeffrey's got 211 Donald has 18 and
obviously Trump has won so we're getting
into that range of let's see oh one nine
well and what they're what they're doing
is they're they're bringing back
um
and they're they're they're they're
they're doing the no votes the people
who didn't vote so
um there should be one more Democrat and
two more Republicans here right yes I
believe so three 220 420 so there's 14
votes left right or no no sorry no no no
no it's fine no there's
19 plus 2. there we go spats what did
she do
[Music]
I think there's three remaining
this is I didn't have I don't have any
questions any
who did not answer their okay so now
they're doing anyone who didn't answer
the call so
um anyone who didn't vote is gonna have
a chance to vote now
um I think there's two
well two or four no no
it's two because it ends in a two so
there's four are you sure yeah look 211
plus 18 is 239 plus one is 240 plus 201
is I'm right now right 441 plus one
you think he's looking at this guy's
venmo or what do you think he's looking
I think uh maybe maybe some uh DMS from
somebody or something somebody says
Donald's did not vote yet interesting
wow maybe he left him oh look at look at
looky looky Insurrection is coming down
okay let's let's
um
who's he going for Mr Perry are not
recorded you are not recorded
Donald's Donald's all right so you have
one left then Scott Perry votes for
Donald's again I think that's it that's
it
is that done
yeah that's it yeah that is that you're
correct you are correct so we have we
have 19 for Donald's one for Trump and
Matt Getz oh my God you know what you
know why the guy who was pushing for
Donald's it's so funny because here's
the thing so Corey Bush was like hey
just those everyone's aware what the
Republican party is doing they're
putting up Donald's as this prop he's
not an actual candidate he's just this
token he's the black dude right it's the
Hershey Walker
oh my God oh my God this is so racist
you're so racist also but it's true
why why is it you being racist and US
pointing at you being racist us being
right get the [ __ ] out of here right I'm
just pointing out that you're being
racist right no I I literally looked at
last night I saw Corey Bush's tweet and
then I saw everyone else that was like
uh oh you're racist for calling him a
prop and calling him this and this and
that and it's like well it is true and
then and even right now you've got Matt
Gates who was one of the people that
pushed Ford Donald all of yesterday
right and then today goes [ __ ] him I'm
out of here and then pushes for Trump
which again if anyone followed this
whole thing Donald Trump got one [ __ ]
vote maybe he'll get more maybe he'll
become an actual like candidate but I
can tell you right now he has officially
lost another election oh my god well
this is this is fantastic the reason why
Matt Gantz I believe
um he voted for Trump is because
everyone called him out yesterday on the
internet for for his promise that he
made that he would nominate Trump which
this is not uh fulfilling his promise
here let me show you the final vote here
as the as the clerks are going to tally
and then announce the final vote this is
the tally here
um that is probably likely that the
clerks will will call for the official
vote which will be the end
of the seventh vote and Kevin McCarthy
will be officially uh Owen seven first
Speaker of the House uh Gabe Sanchez you
said he'd go 20. but Matt Gantz I
believe what he was doing there was
trying to make good on his promise after
being called out because uh same reason
why Donald's is in the position that
he's in because Donald's if you remember
was the 20th vote in the third round the
third ballot uh Donald's move from
McCarthy's column to uh I believe it was
Jim Jordan at the time yes it's hard to
remember yeah so if I go back to my
handy dandy spreadsheet yes it was the
third round he moved and you know what I
think what it was it wasn't intentional
like they walked into this uh Togan
black guy thing accidentally because
Donald's changed his vote and they're
like hey you know what we should do
because the Democrats are are are saying
that there's a historic thing where
where Hakeem Jeffers is the first black
right and the thing is this is one of
those moments where let's say a company
or an entity gets called out and says
hey you actually only hire white people
or you only do this you only and they're
like whoa whoa whoa and then once they
do something right and whether it's
whether it's actually uh it's sincere or
Genuine to correct the problem you now
get called out for now doing something
that's more performative right and this
right here is an example of a group
doing something performative that was
done in a disingenuous way they did it
as a way as a prop to say oh well we're
not the only ones to nominate the first
black man for speaker of the house uh we
did it too
they do it first and you also didn't do
it because you felt it was the right
thing to do you did it because another
group did it because they actually have
a leader who has the skills and the
mindset and the background and the
experience to actually lead a party and
your group is still trying to figure out
how to how to vote for which person
well they did the same thing in Georgia
with the senate race with Herschel
Walker they were like Lindsey Graham's
like oh black people should vote for
Herschel and like right like they were
they were absolutely
trying to make black people believe that
that
Warnock was not black like what in the
[ __ ] what are you talking about there
there's two black candidates but they do
this stupid [ __ ] like you're saying to
pretend like they're not but in the act
of pretending that they're not it is
like Corey bush is saying um I want to
point out some bad karma makes a really
good point here on YouTube
make it a really good point Trump is
Owen one for speaker and like I said he
lost another election
oh and one I wonder if he I wonder how
um how Trump's record's gonna stack up
here I would really prefer if they
switch Donald's to the Donald
um yeah maybe the whole time they're
like we didn't actually mean Byron
Donalds
McDonald's right they're like uh you
guys know Donald Donald and they're just
Donald the Donald
oh my God these [ __ ] juggle heads
okay are we gonna go back dude we want
to go back to the um
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is gonna be a
minute till they come back to this
they're still they're gonna they're
gonna [ __ ] jerk each other off me
like ah who do we who do we vote for now
dude they've been they've here's here's
the thing too also uh McCarthy went from
two because I've got the whole
leaderboard now in front of me so he
went from 203 first round McCarthy won
203 second round 203 third round
202.201 fifth round 201 sixth round 201
seventh round 201 in the last four
rounds McCarthy lost a vote and one of
them went from um
uh spartz uh went from a McCarthy vote
to a present vote and she stayed
consistent and she's also a uh I think
she's new this year right she's from
Indiana she's I think she's new I
thought it was Michigan maybe I don't
know Victoria Sparks ukrainian-born
American politician
um
oh no she's been since 2021 sorry no
never mind uh since 2010 but she is from
Indiana
um
but I mean it really goes to show you
that you don't like you know we talked
about with Bender yesterday if you're
gonna go for the [ __ ] jugular you
better hope that you get a clean cut uh
that is going after after
um
after McCarthy right and McCarthy is
getting weaker like the the shield and
the armor is is getting damaged like
we're watching on a game like we were
[ __ ] playing Mortal Kombat and you're
watching the health go down
right exactly it's not quite there yet
but it's going down lower and lower and
lower just a little bit and if it's
anything if it's not the count itself
it's the morale it's the ego it's the
emotional state of of Kevin McCarthy
knowing that he's not getting any of
these votes back after the first two or
three rounds he's now losing more votes
and getting new names thrown in there
like now he's got to go against
potentially Donald Trump which will be
hilarious because I hope that's what
happens though I hope that's what
happens no no totally I I I want that I
want that I want that I want to watch
Donald Trump lose
Donald Trump release a statement today
oh my god well you know what that might
be a thing
um I want to remind the audience before
we go to this uh Ali Alexander clip
um uh that at the top of the hour we may
cut short just a bit from the show here
because it looks like we're going it's
possible that we will um pick up the
coverage for Midas Touch which if you're
on YouTube if you're on YouTube we will
put the link in to redirect
automatically so you will go straight to
the new coverage if that's the case if
you're on YouTube so if you're not on
YouTube right now make sure to get over
on YouTube so that way if we do uh if I
do pick up their coverage
um you do not miss that coverage as well
as we watch the house floor if they
continue to vote here
um you know we don't know exactly what's
going to happen in the timing of this
but
um so stay tuned for that but let's go
back to the Ali Alexander
um accusing uh MTG Marjorie trailer
green is some car our Hood foot green
um maybe a being a pipe bomber I don't
know let's listen
commitment
from a [ __ ]
what a place to come in he's very uh
fiery right now yeah he's again this
reminds me of the the the I love Hitler
rants from from Kanye just the just the
the shrill and the sound and the I don't
know it just it's something
um
yeah I just got word we are going to um
they're gonna the minus touch is gonna
pass the Baton to us
um at the top of the hour so we will cut
a short here in about 25 minutes or so
our show about five minutes short and
then we will have
a uh we will get
um a redirect Gabe can you can you get
that link from them while we're while
we're going here so we can do a redirect
on our broadcast so what'll what'll
happen is if you're on YouTube if you're
on this broadcast right now as soon as
this broadcast is over as soon as I hit
in broadcast and it cuts off it will
redirect you to the broadcast that I
will be on now I'm gonna take a bit of a
break because you know guys gotta piss
um what are you gonna do I've been
drinking a lot of water this today be to
get over the tequila shots okay so uh it
will redirect directly to the broadcast
that we will be back on
um Gabe I don't know what kind of time
you've got you said that you might have
be in and out
um but um we'll work that out so again
if you're on this broadcast subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast don't forget
that while you're here but um as the top
of the hour closes we will close just a
bit early than we do normally and then
what we will do
is we will it will redirect
automatically to the minus touch Network
um over to their coverage where I will
pick up their coverage of the house
floor
um working there and as I'm looking at
the house floor and they're still
standing around uh trying to figure out
um why why they became politicians Okay
let's listen to Ali Alexander here
called Marjorie Taylor green uh a [ __ ]
and accuser of being a pipe bomber maybe
I don't know
you have got me mistaken for some damn
fool and a fool Ollie Alexander has
never been called
in the coming days I called him
Marjorie Taylor Green in my summation
and the summation of lawyers committed a
crime
that crime is going to be handed to the
state of Georgia and the state of
Georgia will decide whether they
adjudicate that crime or not
I don't think this has to do with the
pipe mom I think this has to do with her
property that she's bought and how she
became a member of Congress essentially
or maybe she or maybe they can prove in
some way that uh she committed perjury
when she was on the stand last year yeah
who knows I'm just trying to think like
what else it could be in the state of
Georgia I don't think this has to do
with the Pint bomber though because but
I also don't know how much I mean look
I'm not saying that marjor Hiller green
didn't do anything illegal right I'm
sure she's done a lot of things that
have been illegal
um it really comes in a question though
if what he's claiming is actually
something
or if he's making a bunch of [ __ ]
fuss about something and it's uh it's in
like a nothing Burger you know
um
so I'm not I'm not exactly sure I'd be
curious I don't know if he'll actually I
mean maybe in the in the second half of
this he'll reveal that uh that he will
see let's keep going we're not seeing
we're hearing because this is why is
this a static image is this like a oh
this is on telegram I see yeah he's on
well it's on cozy TV and then he's he's
got telegram going on the side it's just
so stupid let's listen
the house Ethics Committee
and house rules must exter by the way
Ali Alexander I want you to understand
something there is no Health Ethics
Committee there is no rules committee
because the people you support and you
[ __ ] push
can't get a speaker that is there is no
rules there are no committees there's
not even members of Congress you dumb
[ __ ] Okay let's keep going I
just want to point that out spell
Marjorie Taylor green when this evidence
comes to light
hoe go home I am done with you goddamn
you are lukewarm I am spitting you out
of my mouth you played me and no more
whoa whoa whoa did he have did he just
say I believe he just said that he has
Marjorie Taylor would you ever I mean I
wouldn't want to be within spitting
distance of Marjory Taylor green let
alone be close enough that I have her I
mean the only other person that we know
can comment on this allegedly yeah
allegedly is Alex Stein supposedly
allegedly
according to Baked Alaska who's an
insurrectionist right uh after the whole
Kanye Nick Fuentes Alex Jones Martin
Taylor green
orgy of whatever that was the Nazi orgy
uh she came out and said oh I don't know
who this guy is and he says really bad
stuff and blah blah blah and then Baked
Alaska was like I'm gonna come to Nick
fuentes's defense and came out and said
oh well turns out
that margin Taylor green had an affair
with Alex Stein while she was married oh
well I don't know if that's true or not
you know again allegedly but allegedly
Margie Taylor green
and Alex Stein
were in each other's mouths and maybe
Ellie Alexander also allegedly was in
that Nazi mouth sandwich
I
mean look I I enjoy the infighting
uh not sure how I feel about the visual
of Nazis uh you know or
well it happens you know sometimes ugh I
guess Nazis have to do that kind of
stuff too
um I'm trying to find this redirect
thing but let's let's finish this let's
finish this and I'll get the redirect
done yeah we got a bit of time let's
finish this four
oh no
everyone will know about your drunken
nights because the Consultants you have
drunk with you will have to choose
whether they fear me or whether they
fear you and they fear me Marge
they fear me a lot more than they fear
oh oh God damn I mean he's excited here
uh-huh he's really excited oh my God I I
want to know I wanna know yeah what
drunken night oh and who these
Consultants were sounds like Madison
Gotham type [ __ ] doesn't it
um here's what I'm gonna do I I really
need a break
um for just one just go full screen just
go full screen that's what I'm gonna do
so you go ahead you go and uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna pull the sound up here
and you go ahead and commentate if you
want and well all right so uh all right
go get out get out of here get out here
oh man we just missed it anyway we had
Andrew Clyde on the screen a moment ago
if anyone remembers who Andrew Clyde is
he is the uh January 6 was just another
tourist visit
uh God I hate [ __ ] hate that guy uh
but if you remember Andrew Clyde there's
also a photo of Andrew Clyde very very
scared up against the door in the very
chambers that they're in right now
um when they were scared for their life
um I don't know who these two are but
clearly it's still this like
children can come to work kind of thing
which is very interesting I mean I guess
it's totally fine since they're not
really doing much this week
uh anyway let's see who else we got here
who are these two oh we got Paul gosar
he's fallen asleep right there uh yeah
he's pretty much asleep
and I don't know who's next to him right
now but yeah gosar is unless he's
looking at his phone I'm pretty sure
he's he's drooling on himself
uh we got Matt Gates behind him if you
look at the McCarthy sign that's where
he is right there he's behind him I look
like he's trying to Rally around votes
probably
um
probably to get votes for Trump
potentially if this is actually a
legitimate thing
who else we got over here
uh other side you know I don't know who
these guys are I mean I'm I'm not going
to be I'm not gonna lie guys a lot of
these white dudes you know look the same
you know
uh unless their name was made
popularized or normalized during the
Insurrection I probably wouldn't be able
to recognize them offhand
but I can tell you that all these guys
are a bunch of mediocre fat white
entitled men
um old crusty ball sacks is that what it
is yeah yep yep yep yep it's crazy um
everyone missed it Paul gosar was uh he
looked like he was [ __ ] loaded or he
was falling asleep head was down oh
really yeah you missed he's on the other
side of the aisle oh there we go wait
nope now we're at the Matt Gates so
actually so in front in front is where
gosar is but here's Matt Gates trying to
make whatever you know uh reach around
deals oh reach around yeah
you you're on the free there's and again
there's Andrew Clyde again as I pointed
out this guy's the one who said it's
January 6 was a normal tourist visit but
at the same time
he was [ __ ] fearing for his life up
against the door which was just right up
the aisle from where he is right now
okay I'm glad you brought up um uh goes
are here real quick we showed yesterday
a clip of Matt Getz
an AOC now everyone was wondering what
the hell they said on the house floor as
it was happening and it's hard to read
their lips
um but AOC actually did an interview to
say and I told you yesterday what
happened right I know ahead of the game
I know I know this I know I know I'm
just saying that yesterday that happened
but there was also a moment that
happened
with Paul gozar oh right and AOC that's
where I'm going with this if you just
wait for my transition here no okay all
right you just you just hang on you know
I got the best the best transitions
segue into that one Segway Into the
pogooser Now this may or may not be the
exact lip reading
um translation here it's pretty close
though I think it is pretty pretty close
let's see if this one is as close as the
AOC Matt gets one
you dreamed of draculation while we're
on this sort of stuff you heard of the
Pied Piper well my dream pipe Piper had
toilet paper one shoot of the cheap kind
yes and he took that and he ripped out a
creme brulee and a little tiny pepper
yes before he ate a tree you didn't have
that drink yes I did nope you did not
don't tell me you did it's not true you
didn't never get to dream with a Pied
Piper eating a drink I mean you're
telling me you dreamed that too
guys
then it wasn't as cool as my dream
I mean
hi that that is probably what was said I
mean it's like knowing knowing Paul goes
are and knowing what he said I mean I'm
surprised I had such a civil
conversation knowing Paul gosar's uh
past actions against margiela Green but
that conversation seemed pretty legit I
it I mean eating trees Pied Piper I mean
you know what do you think they were
really talking about there uh he was
like I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you no
um I mean now now give that context
because I know you're kind of joking but
it's right so I'm joking so if you if
anyone remembers or doesn't know Paul
goatsar and AOC he shared an image of
um
of I forget the anime man there's some
kind of anime card I forget which one it
was but anyway he shared an image of of
this anime style edited video and it had
his face on a character and it was
attacking AOC with a Samurai
um it's gross it was uh totally totally
uncalled for
um but it was an assassination anime
uh
uh it was it was out it was it was in
let me see well I don't know if it's
it's on Twitter but let me see if I can
find it um either way it was
it wasn't great so the fact that they're
even having a conversation right now
is a little weird but I'm sure that
she's like yeah sure I'm willing to talk
to you and push down any ideas or
misconceptions that you have around us
budging right because that's what the
gates conversation really was it was him
trying to get a sense of like oh well I
heard that you guys were gonna mush away
we're gonna push away from Jeffries and
you guys are gonna do this and what's
the gauge over here
and um
it turns out that that's really what the
conversation was it was it was Gage
trying to kind of push lies and
misinformation to see if they would also
budge
um on their end but you know that that
didn't happen at all I mean they've been
every single vote all seven votes it has
been two twelve two twelve two twelve
two twelve two twelve two twelves for
Hakeem Jeffries they have not budged
they are here is the uh here's where
they're going to um this is the official
count here that the clerks have got I
got
one
[Applause]
they're all clapping but the guy keeps
losing
well that was like a tapping clap Trump
of the State of Florida has received one
I like how he's the State of Florida
because
that's that's where he's gone to retire
D haven't received the majority of the
votes cast
a speaker has not been elected
Madam clerk I Rise to nominate Kevin
McCarthy for speaker of the house that
fast boom let's just get it going
daytime
[Applause]
thank you
I think at this point we've all heard
about Kevin McCarthy in length
he is my friend
my colleague I'm I'm very proud to say
that oh they're in front I know our
remarks are directed towards the clerk
and the chair but I don't mind saying
I'm directing my marks
to another part of our team and make no
mistake we are a team we are together
okay yeah
seems that way
I would say this to some of my friends
in Texas
I have the same fear
truly that that some of you have
that we squander this opportunity to to
right the wrongs that have gone on here
for the last two and four years and
there are very real wrongs I have that
fear just like you do
I'd say to my friend from Montana
I would say that I have the same fear
you do
that America's gives this chance
to change our course
and that we fail
I have that fear
I would say to my friends from Arizona
I have the same fears that you do
that we don't recover
from the indifference that has been
shown
to the honor we have to serve here
to the responsibility we have to
safeguard our Constitution and the
freedoms of Americans I have that fear
that it can't be recovered from
I would say to my friend the general
from Pennsylvania
that I have the same fears that he has
that we squander we keep doing the same
[ __ ] you notice they say the same [ __ ]
and then they do the same boat and then
they do the same same old speech same
boat it's almost like Kevin McCarthy is
not going to be speaker of that that's
what I'm getting the feeling here the
world difference after three days of
this that he's not going to be the
speaker of that my friend Jim Barry is
it just me also I didn't know
for anyone who doesn't know this
differently
because of what he said and I just
looked this up to confirm and it's a
service in Vietnam what the [ __ ]
we have so many okay hey hang on let me
let me let me mute this um this Brian
Mast from Florida here U.S
representative Brian Mass uh this was in
2020 and he got on a fire for comments
he made on Facebook about a decade ago
joking about rape and sexual relations
with 15 year old girls this is true
posted on Facebook this is something he
joked he posted in public place not like
a DM okay good God
and this is the guy that's going to
nominate
um Kevin McCarthy and you thought George
Santos was a [ __ ] box
I'm telling you he's just any old
average Republican
okay I'm gonna let the audience know why
they're um half-assed clapping
for the person that's not going to be
speaker
um
we are going to redirect to the Midas
touch coverage as soon as this broadcast
is over so if you're on YouTube right
now do not go anywhere when this
broadcast is over if you if you see us
wrapping up and I go to the end stay on
stay on the broadcast because you will
be redirected automatically to our
coverage that we will go to
um to the Midas touch that is currently
ongoing we're going to help out over
there for their coverage so if you are
here with us right now stay with us if
you have time if you want to keep
watching coverage of the vote for the
speaker of the house now here's what's
going to happen it'll redirect
and then I'm going to take a bit of a
break uh maybe get some more coffee to
offset the tequila shots from last night
see last week Gabe it was pickle shots
um last week this week it was tequila so
which would you rather have would you
rather do the tequila or the pickle
shots you know what pickled juice shots
yeah I would rather do pickle because I
feel like once you take a whiskey shot
the pickle juice cuts it right I I like
that I like the pick I mean it tastes
like pickle juice but I mean you know I
like pickles but it's a little I don't
drink the juice out of the pickles you
just can't have too much pickle juice
right and this is important stuff is
we're um uh commentating on the house
Lord vote for the speaker of the house
um apparently it was a bad thing for
Democrats to drink of course I had been
drinking but you know that's just the
way it goes sometimes
um again everyone who is here on the
Joni Michaels podcast on the YouTube
channel don't forget to subscribe and if
you're not on YouTube you can come on
over here
that's the only place that it will
automatically go to the new coverage is
YouTube that's the only place that I can
do that with I think
um but you can go to mind it says
Facebook page you'll be able to watch
the coverage there But Here on YouTube
it'll redirect you automatically to
their coverage as soon as we exit
um so don't when you hear the theme
music go down you can say goodbye and
stuff but stay on this link it'll
redirect automatically if you're on
YouTube also download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast on
Apple Spotify Google leave us a great
review why you're there and follow us on
Twitter at Tony at Tony Michaels pod
because you're going to be able to vote
for bone end of the week I I wonder Gabe
I'm just wondering who the bone net of
the week is going to be hmm who could it
possibly be
would it be the biggest loser of the
week I don't know I mean I don't know
there's many many losers I highly I
highly doubt that this guy right here on
screen will not
um McCarthy definitely there's no way
he's he's gonna he's gonna Dodge being
bone end of the week yeah no [ __ ]
wait he he definitely cannot win the
speaker vote but he sure as hell
who wins something this week oh he's
gonna win bone into the weak boat for
sure best show you think I we're gonna
have we're gonna have a bigger margin
um
for Kevin McCarthy probably than what he
has in his own caucus right now that's
crazy but it is up to you for bone end
of the week so don't forget to vote for
bone of the week again you can vote here
on YouTube so don't forget to subscribe
but also go to Twitter and follow us at
Tony Michaels pod you'll be able to vote
there and tomorrow in the second hour
somehow someway I don't know how we're
gonna do it with this coverage ongoing
but we are going to do bonehead of the
week it's going to be strange and weird
maybe but we are gonna do it
he's whacking chuckleheads they're
making our job difficult in these time
slots you know that yeah it's like they
don't know that we have you know that we
got time slots and stuff that we're
commenting on [ __ ] they're doing can't
they do this in the appropriate
um timeline so that it's easier on us
why can't they do this I don't know I
don't know I don't know okay so let's go
back to the house floor here and see
what these losers and how they're losing
let's see I vouch that he will deliver
that opportunity to us I'm proud to
stand before my country and say that
Kevin McCarthy is different he is
different that is why for those that I
was speaking to earlier the process is
where it is today what the [ __ ]
yesterday they were like uh no one
trusts him and now he's like he's
different like bad different maybe good
you'll get a term limits Bill and then
you won't
these stupid idiots are fighting about
their own power inside their caucus
wasteful spending pass this is why they
can't win
that's not him he's different he's not
John Boehner
he didn't throw you all that disagreed
with him out on your cans and say I
don't want to hear from you I don't want
to listen to you he welcomed everybody
in because he's different
and if we give him the chance to be our
speaker
we will all be different he will be
different this Congress will be
different and our country will be
different wait so he is different but
then if he's gonna be different I I
don't I can't it's the name of Kevin
McCarthy very proudly as the next
speaker of the house I don't get like if
he was already good enough like he's
he's propping him up and he goes look
he'll be different
so is he different than the than him
already being different he's gonna kiss
him he's got to go down there he's got
to give him a hug yeah oh thank you so
much bro thank you so much for getting
up there and saying that was amazing so
what was the post that this game posted
on Facebook did you actually find the
[ __ ] post yeah hold on let me let me
open back up
uh so we're gonna go to the um uh the
Democrat side which again let's listen
in
[Applause]
again Democrats still holding the house
floor
to make sure that the Republicans are
held accountable for their leader
212 212.
[Laughter]
212.
God damn they make it so easy
212. house
they make it so [ __ ] easy
it's amazing that they even won the
majority in the house they make it so
easy
swell house Democrats stand United
behind our leader because Hakeem Jeffrey
stands United for the Americans Ain't
Gonna Change [ __ ]
oh man
like they can't even pick one person
I want to tell the audience why this is
so important now again we've talked
about this with David Benner and they've
said it before and we'll keep saying it
Nancy Pelosi is one of the most
effective if not the most effective
speaker of the house that's ever held
that position I believe she's most
effective in modern times but I I don't
know how she Stacks up against you know
his in history but I'm sure she's at
least in the top five if not the top
three if she's not the actual uh most
effective but here's the thing is that
our last Congress the 117th had the same
margin on the Democratic side that the
Republicans and that's about the same
pretty close pretty close
and look how much [ __ ] they got done and
we could go through the line items of
the [ __ ] that they got done but there's
no use of doing that you can go look it
up and if you can't look it up well yeah
I can't help you but here's the thing
the reason why the Democratic caucus is
212 behind Akeem Jeffries is because
weeks ago Nancy Pelosi in the proper way
handed off the leadership baton to
Hakeem Jeffries at that time
and and that is the reason why the
Democrats can hold the floor here and
hold the 212 is because they have real
serious people in Congress and they have
real leadership that is how this works
the reason why the Republicans are
having such trouble is because they are
not leaders they do not give a [ __ ]
about the process they do not give a
[ __ ] about your vote and your
constituency they do not give a [ __ ]
they only care about one thing that they
keep talking about in interviews and on
the house floor what committee are you
going to give me how much power am I
gonna get me me I want to be in front of
the cameras I want to hold a gavel I
want to have power give me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me
the reason why you're King Japanese is
getting 212 is because Nancy Pelosi was
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives
we the people's house
and she passed the Baton of we of the
people's house
two Hakeem Jeffries and her caucus in
the correct manner that a leader would
pass it and that is the most important
thing of why Democrats can hold to 12 as
Catherine Clark here representative
elect Catherine Clark points out so well
when she's like 212 212 212 212-12 and
we're going to keep going to 212 212 212
212. because Nancy Pelosi was an
effective leader she's an effective
speaker and she effectively handed off
the Baton of leadership to an another
effective leader who is keeping his
caucus in order and he was keeping the
vote at 212 and making sure that
Republicans are held accountable on the
floor for picking their majority leader
and to to vote for a speaker of the
house I don't know if I can say it any
better than that what do you got before
we go because I am going to end this
just a few minutes early again again
before you before you give your last
statement everyone stick around on this
link it'll redirect to the next coverage
on the mightiest touch Channel again
it'll automatically redirect so stick
around go ahead Gabe give us your last
word um yeah the only thing I really got
to say is I mean like I I want to
emphasize you know double down on what
you said but also like this is a group
the Democratic party knows exactly what
they want they know exactly what they
need to do to get it done and they know
they know exactly how they plan to help
the American people and the Republican
party doesn't want that they just want
Power they just want influence they just
want to be famous
but they're going to end up and have
ended up being Infamous in this moment
of holding America hostage because I
cannot settle on one person they can't
even rally around one [ __ ] person now
they've gone from two to three to two to
like they they can't make up their mind
uh and meanwhile they're throwing in the
name of the former president the guy
who's under multiple investigations in
multiple States for multiple different
crimes this party is a laughable a group
of people it's a [ __ ] clown circus
stuffed into a car
they cannot make a choice they cannot
figure out what they want they just
continue to point fingers meanwhile
the complete opposite in contrast black
and white in terms of comparison is
you've got the Democratic party rallied
around one person who actually has
leadership qualities experience and the
skills necessary to lead America through
legislation that will help everyday
Americans
but here we go with Andy Biggs throwing
out who knows maybe he's going to throw
out Byron Donald's again or maybe he'll
throw out the Donald who knows but they
can make up their mind they're
completely lost their [ __ ] lost at
sea
and they have no way to see in the
Horizon where they need to go well
there's holes in the boat and they're
trying to pale it out but they can't
everyone thanks for joining us here on
the Tony Michaels podcast for the third
day I am sure tomorrow we will be on the
fourth day of Kevin McCarthy being The
Biggest Loser a bigger loser than Donald
John Trump as Matt Gantz put it everyone
remember this is going to redirect to a
link to Midas Touch as soon as this
broadcast is over so as soon as our
ending theme music is over it will
redirect remember that do not go
anywhere stay right here on the
broadcast and you will see continuing
coverage of Kevin McCarthy losing again
what will be it's really it's really
honestly it's a it's a it's a
Groundhog's Day uh type scenario we keep
seeing the same outcome you know
that is a great movie and it's uh gonna
continue to be this way maybe for a
couple weeks we'll see everyone stick
around again it's going to redirect the
link stick around
but until tomorrow at this podcast
Surfs Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon